[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm charging like a bull when it's on
it's all
this isn't about just winning the match
pride and bragging rights are at stake
both fighters will need to bring their a
game to the table
both fighters have plenty of power where
is this map going to go
how are they going to deal damage what's
the play here
player one has them legit shook in the
corner
who will they hit
with or even charge in tricky territory
here
definitely shuts out the jumper
what's the play here
is going to have a hard time managing
their drive now
this is a critical point of the round
where they just need to go for it
player one is maintaining the snakes in
the throw
player one picks up the first round
that'll give them a psychological
advantage
[Music]
see
this round is so important you can feel
the intensity in the air
seeing how that round wound up very
close how will both sides tackle the
next
this is the perfect range to reach out
and tag them with something
the quarter makes it hard to escape
what'll be the setup
player 2 is working with a less than
ideal drive game they'll need to be very
careful here
drive gauge is almost empty they gotta
be careful
super hard on deck for both fighters how
they approach the situation will be
interesting
break those shins
go wow
both fighters planning something
life lead is there but still anyone's
game
our fighters are at a standstill what's
the play here this is
flying
good heads-up decision opting for the
dragon pass it's back with the drive
impact on the recovery this punish
counter presents a huge chance
the lord
oh here we go
feeling a real buzz
dangerous range here
doing some quick planning
okay
this is our destiny this is going to
kill
absolute carnage
[Music]
[Applause]
look at all my haters y'all making them
all right you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no escape
now you understand
don't underestimate me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
keep walking
[Music]
apricot
i gotcha
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when
[Music]
the top player is here this will be a
good fight
[Music]
[Music]
my turn
[Music]
round two five
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
real wins
[Music]
[Applause]
round one
[Music]
who you can
[Music]
[Music]
fluffy
[Music]
in my world
we're all feeling it
round two
fighting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
fight
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
real wins
[Music]
[Applause]
are y'all trying to play the sidelines